your girl and that butcher's boy
attacked my son
that animal of hers nearly tore his arm
off that's not true
she just bit him a little
he was hurting micah a big favorite of
people that i speak to is
arya the little girl rejecting all the
conventions
of her sex to become this young warrior
she was one of my favorites right from
the beginning
i mean people often ask me who's my
favorite character and my answer is
always tyrion but
but arya is probably the the second
favorite and it's pretty
pretty close she's always a joy to write
macie williams
what a fine she was i we looked through
hundreds of girls for arya
and she's become a real favorite in the
tv show
the remarkable thing for me was this is
a genre that i'd not looked at before
and i wasn't expecting to find these
characters
that i can really identify with and i
was seeing you know these are people
from a world that
that don't really exist but they're
having the same kind of problems that i
do
yeah i've always felt that character is
the heart of fiction
if you make the characters real then
the rest of the furniture around them is
is almost incidental you'll still have a
powerful story
you'll still have a story that will
involve and affect your
your readers so for me character is is
really what
uh what fiction is all about with the
the characters in the game of thrones
they're very three-dimensional that you
get to know all their characteristics
their people you would sit next to at
dinner they're not worried about
retrieving a magic amulet from somewhere
you know they're worried about
who's going to kill them or whether
they're going to get to eat next week or
who they're going to have sex with next
he's certainly an incredible master of
plot and of character
i think throughout this immense series
of novels you get
constant shifts and developments in
character which is the mark of a really
really good
writer away with you dog
you're scaring my lady
i don't like to see you upset you're a
very
accessible author uh yes
which has good and bad to it i tell you
it just never dawned on me to uh
to erect all these uh protective walls
about myself
when you go to the conventions and to
the book signings do you
still just feel like a fanboy yourself
going and
looking at the merchandise and meeting
people that are like you or do you feel
like you've moved to another
plane now i can remember book signings
back in the in the 80s and uh where
where uh
no one would come obviously those days
have gone and i saw with each
volume of ice and fire the crowds have
gotten bigger
and with feast for crows and would dance
with dragons the last two books
the crowds have been enormous